two new professional photos have just
been released of Harry and Megan what is
your takeaway of these new images well
it's all in the timing isn't it it was
quite polarizing because you you had
just two days before that incredible
image of Charles and Camilla the new
Prince and Princess of Wales it said
this is the future of the monarchy and
of course so notable by their absence
was Harry and Megan this is clearly the
sussexes just making a point here we
have an alternative Royal Court across
the pond we're visible we're bold and
we're not going anywhere yeah they can
do Royal a different way we're doing
exactly we're doing Royal different way
what do you know about Harry and Megan's
return to the US after the Queen's death
I think they probably returned to
California with very mixed emotions
grief possibly some regret over how
things had panned out I mean don't
forget that Harry and Megan were invited
to go to balma moral to spend a weekend
with the queen with their children in
that summer they chose not to go
more Royal tidbits Charles Dick named
Megan tungsten because of her resilience
and the King was quote sometimes
irritated that Kate's rocks got more
media attention than his good works this
morning back in the States Megan dropped
a new episode of her podcast but Katie
says it's Harry's upcoming Memoir that
really has the Royals worried quite
simply they don't know what to expect
there's a lot of rumors that Prince
Harry is making possibly last minute
edits to the book is edited to the
Queen's death well the The Queen's death
and and and also in light of the Queen's
death the sensitivity perhaps of some of
the passages that he's written about and
so the autobiography has been shrouded
in secrecy Harry has taken a 35 million
dollar advance when you're having that
sort of an advance that's not going to
be for Harry talking about his
philanthropic work I think we're going
to see him shed a lot of light on why he
left in this new book we know that you
know Charles did have some conversations
with Harry while he was over there that
there is this flicker of hope that there
can be a Reconciliation and as I say in
the book it is his genuine hope that he
can smooth things out I mean not least
because it doesn't look good for the
monarchy to have a rift at the center of
it but as a father he wants to sort
things out as a grandfather he wants to
have a relationship with his
grandchildren but there are big issues
that need to be sorted out and not least
the fact that Harry and Megan keep
reaching the confidence and Trust of the
royal family what's going to happen with
the titles of Archie and Lily Bear right
if Charles gives them those titles and I
think it's a big if that comes with a
cost that's going to come with an
expectation of loyalty and Trust
[Music]